2021 was a great year for xbox series x
and s we got games like microsoft flight
simulator forza horizon 5 and of course
halo infinite not to mention lots of
massive game pass drops and even more
cloud gaming options and after a bunch
of delays acquisitions and announcements
2022 is shaping up to be an even bigger
year for the consoles in this video
we're going over a list of our most
anticipated upcoming xbox games listed
in alphabetical order not order of
importance so put the pitchfork down
obsidian entertainment had the chance to
make their own fallout game but it has
never had a shot at a fantasy first
person game like the elder scrolls and
it's finally getting its shot with
avowed an rpg set in the world of eora
first featured in the pillars of
eternity games it looks to be in very
early development but seeing as the game
is coming to xbox series x and s and pc
only it won't have to compromise in
order for it to run properly on last gen
hardware it's also far more likely that
we'll see it before the elder scrolls 6
but more on that in a little bit
crossfire x is the xbox version of a pc
based shooter that found huge success in
china and south korea with a variety of
free online multiplayer modes however
what really makes crossfire x exciting
is its campaign mode which is being
developed by remedy entertainment of max
payne and control fame
in addition to star field but that's the
game studios is developing the elder
scrolls six and it's unquestionably one
of the industry's most anticipated games
after skyrim's unbelievable and enduring
success over the past 10 years bethesda
is following it up with a sequel that
has very big shoes to fill we've only
seen a brief teaser trailer so far but
it was enough to get fans hyped
specifics about the story and direction
of the game are unknown but we do know
that the elder scrolls 6 and starfield
for that matter will be powered by an
upgraded engine that bethesda boss todd
howard says represents the biggest
overhaul ever
what is everwild we don't really know
and that could be because despite an
early trailer showing a whimsical forest
filled with magic developer rare has
reportedly had trouble nailing down the
core design elements early on at the
time of its announcement it was
primarily a third person adventure game
with with god game elements and it
appears rare doesn't want to rush into
showing off more until it nails down
exactly how to move forward on the
project
the fable series has been on ice for a
couple years with a multiplayer spin-off
getting cancelled after its beta period
last generation and the panned fabled
the journey releasing for connect on
xbox 360 before that however the newest
game which is apparently a reboot touted
as a new beginning for the series is
developed by the open world masters at
playground games thus far the studio's
output has been limited to the forza
horizon games so it remains to be seen
how it will handle a fantasy rpg
the other half of the forza franchise
forza motorsport appears to be getting a
reboot of sorts with the simply titled
well forza motorsport developed by long
time forza studio turn 10 the game will
only be available on xbox series x and s
and pc meaning it should be able to
better leverage the newer hardware the
game doesn't yet have a release window
or many gameplay details but an
in-engine teaser trailer is so
stunningly realistic that's difficult to
tell it's actually a video game and not
real life
thanks to lucasfilm expanding its
licensing deals we're getting more games
based on the company's iconic franchises
and one of these is a new indiana jones
games from the makers of the new
wolfenstein games very little is known
about the indiana jones game but
bethesda veteran todd howard an indiana
jones superfan is producing it in fact
he's been trying to get it off the
ground for a decade already so it's been
a long time in the works given that
machine games is now owned by xbox you
can expect the title to be exclusive to
xbox and pc but this hasn't been
confirmed
created by new studio the initiative and
billed as a quadruple a game whatever
that means perfect dark is an espionage
game that follows in the footsteps of
rare's original adventures starring
joanna dark a short teaser trailer
focused on the role corporations had in
the continued dystopian unraveling of
mankind is all we've seen thus far of
the game though it does confirm that
joanna herself will be featured in the
game the initiative aims to quote
reimagine the franchise for a new
generation though it remains to be seen
exactly how that will play out the
original nintendo 64 game took heavy
inspiration from rare's previous title
goldeneye 007
the next game from arcane studios
creators of the dishonored series and
death loop looks to be quite a departure
the cooperative first person shooter
coming summer 2022 to xbox series xs and
pc tasks you and your friends with
destroying the vampire plague that has
overrun the town it allows for
single-player gameplay as well and
arcane promises that it retains the
studio's signature level design to help
it stand out from other competitive
shooters with character customization
and special abilities alongside vampires
human enemies dedicated to worshiping
the vampires will also stand in your way
and hopefully your bullets weigh
the first hellblade was a flawed but
refreshingly unique take on the hack and
slasher genre combining it with a
psychological horror tale focused on the
mental health of senua as she attempts
to save her dead lover's soul now with
the backing of microsoft formerly
independent studio ninja theory is
revisiting senua with senua saga
hellblade 2. sending her to iceland for
reasons currently unclear
the next role-playing game from the
legendary bethesda studios and the first
not involving elder scrolls or fallout
starfield is aiming for something
remarkably different from either series
its approach to science fiction role
playing will be grounded in reality
fitting into the hard sci-fi subgenre
associated with films like the arrival
and the martian given the emphasis
science fiction games tend to put on
realizing the impossible this should
certainly make starfield stand out and
you can still expect immense scale and
plenty of exploration opportunities when
it hits xbox series x and s and pc in
november of 2022
zombie games are so common nowadays that
you can barely go a week without a new
one releasing but undead labs state of
decay games are unique in how they blend
direct third person action with base and
resource management the result is a
story all your own and one that often
leads to unexpected outcomes with the
studio now part of microsoft it will
hopefully receive an even larger budget
in order to polish state of decay 3 when
it eventually releases
obsidian entertainment is best known for
making sequels to already established ip
like fallout and star wars knights of
the old republic but in recent years it
has been able to flex his creative
muscles with more original creations the
outer worlds was a short but sweet first
person rpg that makes biting political
satire with great characters and
character progression that allowed you
to permanently hamstring your own
abilities in order to increase them in
another area the outer worlds 2 now made
with the company as an internal
microsoft studio looks to improve on the
original hopefully making it a bit
longer in the process
tunic or the cute fox game as we like to
call it is a classic exploration action
adventure in the vein of zelda and the
developers specifically took inspiration
from the original game because of its
lack of direction or clear objectives
given to the player this is what
encourages true exploration and
discovery which is at the heart of any
good adventure game and the puzzles will
also not be so video gaming so as to
break the immersion tunic will be
available on xbox one xbox series xns
and pc on march 16th 2022
from the developers of warhammer
vermintide darktide is a four-player
co-op action game that introduces a
deeper gunplay system to the warhammer
games dark tide takes place in the hive
city of tertium and you play a convict
turn agent who's aiding in a mission to
exterminate chaos cultist corruption the
game is currently scheduled to release
in spring of 2022. what's your most
anticipated xbox exclusive of 2022 let
us know in the comments below
you